[Applause]
but you all know the big story sad day
for inbreeding
[Laughter]
queen elizabeth died at 96 they say the
cause of death was meghan markle's
podcast
[Laughter]
no i liked the queen i did the her
personal estate they said was worth
almost half a billion dollars used to be
worth a billion
that's what you get for listening to
matt damon
uh but the
the white house is saying for a long
time they didn't know whether biden was
going to go to the funeral they finally
said just a few hours ago he is going to
i was not in doubt
biden funeral
[Laughter]
that's right
it's like when the dog hears your keys
you know i mean
[Laughter]
you know biden sent his condolences to
the uh people of england and said we can
do anything we're here to for your to be
your friend and trump also uh sent
condolences and said
they could bury her in his golf course
[Laughter]
oh and i mean
condolences are coming in from all over
of course the british people very upset
about this is that you elton john is
writing a new song
it's called mustard in the fridge
well he's noting the fact that diana was
36 and the queen is almost 100 and
mustered in the fridge
seems to me you lived your life
like mustard in the fridge
we're all upset
i called buckingham palace to give my
condolences they said new queen who dis
you know who you know who's very glad
the queen is dead queuing on any q and
on people here i always welcome i say
everybody's welcome at my show
but kewanon they think the queen was
part of the child trafficking ring that
was eating babies
but she lived to 96. i say pass the baby
you